all right here we go eight sterling
treasure boxes pay to look good oh it's
got that hearthstone type thing that is
aspect our glove not what I want but
we're getting chroma yeah you pretty
much got like one of each chroma when
you open up one of each color expect our
gloves again this is paid to lose so you
got Vanguard rip boosters I don't care
about that they last for you and your
team spect ours vest where is the taken
what is this dan bad luck Eric what is
this trash right now oh my god rip rip
in pieces oh this games orangey good
seriously through was that four pairs of
gauntlets now and three and three three
three and three at least give me the set
at this point okay all right that's a
hunter's mask though come on boots and
that's a hunter I'm so done right now so
done right available see Eric playing
the division and Dark Souls 3 you
kidding yes even I got no taken armor a
lot of streams burning of his division
disk eight packages destiny disk
packages and we didn't get one you get
one when you get one frickin are you
[ __ ] me right now you're totally
shafted so how many how many was that
was at seven that's 88 how much is that
in real moneys so they're two hundred or
200 / you can x 2304 20 bucks so you're
getting it's about two bucks a box that
was 1,600 silver nah yeah those see what
you got one for free from yeah and I
didn't do the 41 POA yet but you know
yeah Yolo
when things go bad you just spend more
money just ban biggie the game oh thank
you there it is urk that's a helm cloak
in the helm suspect our clothes that's a
chest go orange Jesus crazy come on
that's not a that's not it that's not a
desolate Eric apparently we're more
better than IGN lying to be the gamer in
our chat why's that we're more better
than idea that's good I think he likes
he likes watching me oh why why the time
beside account towards the emote maybe
please please oh wait whoa no no no no
we're full on something we're full on
something good chick hold on we can at
least we can at least semi cosplay here
we got we got some cosplay I don't have
it that airplane 747 like a derp a derp
of a derp a derp is like you forgot to
put your pants on in the morning oh you
can't be stocking like this shall I take
a message no Victor fresh respect our
trash so that was 15 boxes and I only
got three pieces of desolate find a way
to not look so stupid there you go i
look less stupid now like you're being
initiated into bacon i am not taking
enough this is what twenty dollars can
yet you guys uh three pieces of desolate
armor for another twenty dollars you may
get the other pieces but you may also
get another class that's a stream
you